[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight if you've been paying attention
recently you probably have you've likely
sense that something profound is
happening to this country right now
something that could transform what
America is you can feel it happening
our leaders deny it officials on both
sides reassured us they're not planning
wholesale changes to the country they're
just trying to fix specific problems a
man was brutalized by police officers in
Minneapolis another man was shot to
death in the parking lot of Wendy's
those things were bad they're telling us
and abuses like that are what they are
fighting against they say we need new
laws more good faith more attention to
injustice and that sounds right to most
Americans Americans are decent people
they want to do the right thing
certainly Republicans in Congress who
appear to believe all of this or maybe
they're just so scared they pretend they
believe it either way just yesterday the
GOP leadership enthusiastically backed a
law enforcement reform bill they're
proud of that they seem to think that
reining in the police will fix the
underlying problems and pretty soon we
can all get back to living in 2014 again
Republicans appear to believe this is a
policy debate but Democrats know better
than that they don't lie to themselves
they understand there is a revolution in
progress the death of George Floyd may
have sparked widespread outrage sincere
outrage and they may share that outrage
but they also know that what is
happening now has very little to do with
George Floyd or people like him like all
revolutions the point is to destroy the
current system and replace it with
something new but replace it with what
that's the question the rest of us
should be asking right now we should
know what's coming we know we have now
our current system has been in place for
hundreds of years it's based on a very
simple idea all people are created by
God with equal moral value period every
one of them for that reason and that
reason alone
all Americans are treated equally under
the laws of the United States in this
country we judge you for what you do not
how you were born that idea has been the
defining principle of America since the
18th century it's the main reason we are
the fairest Society in the world
it's the reason people move here so the
extent of America has failed to live up
to that principle of equality we are
ashamed of it we should be equality is
the most important thing we have we
should defend it we should practice it
now for the first time in our history
we're witnessing a broad and powerful
attack on the principle of equality
daily we are told that all people are
not in fact created equal
some are born with moral stain others
were not some Americans are guilty some
are innocent nothing can change this
because was all determined at birth all
we can do is respond accordingly people
in favor groups must be held to one
standard those in disfavored groups the
morally tainted ones must be held to
another standard the country retains one
set of laws mostly for the sake of
formality but we must apply those laws
in very different ways according to the
DNA in the background of the accused if
that sounds familiar it's because this
kind of system we just described a
system based on heredity and blood guilt
has been very common in history it was
the rule in feudal Europe for example in
the totalitarian regimes on that
continent more recently it's still in
practice in parts of the world in North
Korea children are sent to prison camps
for the sins of their ancestors and
unfortunately we have seen it here too
you may have wondered how politicians
could have justified practices as
perverse as slavery and Jim Crow in a
country or the Constitution like ours
and the answer is simple by arguing that
not all people are created equal some
had lesser moral value from birth that's
what they said those people carried the
stain of sin with them you were allowed
to treat them differently based on who
they were at the time many understood
that this was a lie
slavey persisted for hundreds of years
but there were always some an authority
who considered an evil not evil simply
because it was abusive which of course
it was but because the existence of it
violated the central principle of this
country and they were right where are
those people now look around
is anyone empowered defending absolute
equality under the law if there was ever
a time to remind America that we all
have equal value under God that time is
right now but now no one in charge is
saying
our leaders are cowards when we need
them to be brave
they are muddled when we need them to
think clearly it's possible they no
longer even believe in equality 40 years
ago this was a middle class country and
as a result America had strongly a Galit
Aryan values pretty much everyone used
commercial airports in Aden McDonald's
remember that people talked without
irony about their rights as citizens and
taxpayers you couldn't pay extra to jump
to the head of the line at Disney World
the idea that someone like Jeffrey
Epstein could beat a sexes charge
because he was rich would have shocked
us then we would have demanded an
investigation into just how Jeffrey
Epstein died why because Americans hated
corruption they saw corruption as an
offense against equality that was 40
years ago things been moving in the
opposite direction ever since we now
accept uncritically the claim that some
people deserve better treatment based on
how they were born and some deserve
worse this is the most poisonous and the
most destructive of all ideas other
nations understand that Rwanda has made
it a crime to make ethnic appeals during
elections to practice identity politics
because they know very well where that
leads yet identity politics is
accelerating here it shouldn't surprise
you that most of the people pushing this
poison are benefiting from it they're
using the recent chaos to codify
dangerous trends already in progress a
permanently unequal Society where some
citizens are elevated and others are
crushed winners and losers preordained
by law that's the country they're
working toward at the same time and this
is always the tell they lecture you with
maximum self-righteousness about how
they're doing precisely the opposite of
that what they're really doing they
claim is upholding equality under the
law no one is above the law nobody no
one is above the law no one is above the
law no one's above the law no one is
above the law
that no person is above the law nobody
should be above the law no no one is it
possible no one is above the law of a
school's meaning you aren't you were not
above their laws you must obey those
laws to the letter or you will face
certain punishment others meanwhile get
a pass or an entirely separate set of
laws revolutionaries don't acknowledge
universal standards increasingly they
admit this out loud they're not
pretending anymore in California
Democrats are moving to repeal
proposition 209 209 explicitly bans
racial discrimination in hiring and
education in other words Democrats in
California are now fighting for
discrimination this is not considered
strange in 2020 no one even mentions it
a couple of weeks ago Governor Andy
Beshear of Kentucky announced plans to
bring universal health insurance to his
state but not for all citizens just for
people with the right skin color
everyone else would pay but only certain
ethnic groups would benefit Andy Beshear
is still in office tonight no one has
tried to impeach him for suggesting this
because ideas like this are everywhere
now they're totally unchallenged this is
the most divisive possible way to run a
country if you wanted to make certain
that your children would hate each other
you would hold them to different
standards and they certainly would there
is a reason that racial tension is
rising in this country it's by design
but race is not the only dividing line
the coronavirus lock downs have nothing
to do with race with white or black
thank god they're probably the only
thing in America right now that doesn't
quarantine czar instead
scientific they're purely a matter of
public health that's what they told us
and we believe them we said passively as
they destroyed our country's economy as
they indicted Americans for trying to
make a living and then the black lives
matter riots started and we learned that
it was all fake the very same officials
who threatened us with the rest for
going outside urged their own voters to
flood the streets and they did and no
one was punished how could this happen
it was such a flagrant double standard
not even hidden right in your face they
didn't try to explain
they didn't bother to justify it why
anyone familiar with totalitarian
regimes can tell you exactly why and
what's going on this is ritual
humiliation forcing people to accept
mistreatment is a time-tested way to
subdue them of course we're not treating
you fairly they're telling us you don't
deserve fairness you deserve what you
get that's the message and after a while
the population accepts this some believe
it they blame themselves that's the goal
but we should never accept it the
promise of absolute equality under the
law is all we have laws are designed to
protect the weak not the strong at the
moment the people leading this
revolution against our system are strong
that's where they're trying to subvert
our laws if they succeed there will be
nothing to protect the rest of us in
this country we cannot let them do that
in the United States of America all of
us are equal under the law period say
that as loud as you can